[Music]
[Music]
thank you
um
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and all other manner of people
that by the command of our lord the king
of france
it is strictly prohibited
on pain of death and the loss of
property
for anyone here in the arms
for to carry a sword or dagger
unless he be one who has the express
permission
of our lord the king
each man is to fight
on horseback and on foot
and if a man that pleases him with any
weapon on device of attack
except
for weapons for devices of equal
design or made with charms or spells or
any other thing that is forbidden by god
and holy church to all good christians
if either combatant shall carry on to
the field of battle any arms have been
forged with spells
charms enchantments or any other
evilness
and so shall the male factor be punished
as an enemy of god
or as a traitor
or doesn't matter
tighter tighter
[Music]
uh
uh
nicely
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
i will not be patronized
by this squire
who lies about court
waiting to be fated with gift
upon gift upon gift
and risks
nothing nothing
he may acquire more property
in this world
find more favor
eat more drink more
bed more
and otherwise call himself a man of arms
but in this hall
and any other
in my company
he will call me sir
sir
sir
indeed
good sir
enjoy your time in paris
sir
you knew what would happen to me should
you lose this duel
you knew and you didn't tell me god will
not punish those who tell the truth
my fate and our child's fate will be
written not by god's will
by which old man will die first
until you speak to me this morning what
if i don't lose you i begged you to find
another way and now i might be banned in
life
i am risking my life for you hmm
you are risking
my life
so you can fight your enemy and save
your pride
and that could render our child an
orphan
what did you not think of that
there is only one question that matters
do you swear on your life
that what you say is true
[Applause]
my father told me my life will be
blessed with good fortune
i'm married
i was a good wife
and then was
judged and shamed by my country
[Applause]
i say before all of you
i spoke the truth
[Music]
the most unspeakable charge has been
brought against you
chaklagree entered our home
he attacked me
the accusation is false
i am telling the truth
the truth does not matter
there is only the power of men
this should be settled
quietly
innocent
i request a duel to the death if you
lose your wife will suffer dire
consequences
one of us has lied let us let god decide
you do not believe me
i am risking my life for you you are
risking my life so you can save your
pride
penalty
forbearing false witness
is that you are to be burned
alive
i will not be silent
[Applause]
so
you